nursing home patients making up more
than a third of all coronavirus deaths
in the United States the virus has
killed more than 35,000 patients New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo is taking
heat over States disastrous coronavirus
response requiring those homes to admit
patients who tested positive for the
virus one of those people who lost loved
ones was her own Janis Dean she lost
both of her in-laws and spoke about it
last night this should be one of the
biggest stories of this pandemic
of 2020 20% of our lost loved ones are
from nursing homes and it's because
Governor Cuomo and several other
governors by the way in different states
forced Kovan recovering patients into
nursing homes they called Shawn to tell
him they were moving him to another
floor and I believe that floor was used
for recovering kovat patients he got a
call on a Saturday morning that his dad
was not feeling well and three hours
later he was dead and even more outraged
today after a video surfaced of an
elderly man being brutally attacked in a
Detroit nursing home the video is so
disturbing we decided not to show it in
full the attacker a fellow resident at
the facility has been charged
Greg me to go to you first your thoughts
on this first on I would hope on Andrew
Cuomo and this disastrous decision in
New York I watched genestein last night
and it was really disturbing to watch it
really touched me
yeah there's basically just three points
I think Cuomo got a free ride thanks to
the dog and pony show he was doing at
CNN with his brother everybody thought
that was just so funny in hilarious they
chose to go after the Florida governor
instead number two about this attack it
happened in Michigan who was the
Attorney General in Michigan
Dana Nestle right the same one who
freaked out about the mask yeah does has
she had made a comment about this at all
she felt that she could arrest the
people at the Ford Motor Company over a
mask has said nothing about this
horrendous thing and by last my last
point is a bigger point is that we're
doing a terrible job in general in
dealing with our elderly population we
need to upgrade
in revamp the nursing-home structures
and facilities think about new ways to
house people we always talk about all
children are our future who gave them
their damn future it sees 80 and 90 year
old who fought in wars who raised these
people who now some of them don't know
where they are they need care we have so
much compassion for the children
oh the teachers are underpaid the kids
they need no no no we are taking people
who are basically containers of wisdom
and we're shoving them in closets
because they're in the way so it's not
just a bit you know the pandemic did a
lot of things it's stress tests
different parts of our lives right we
were learning about family about
medicine about government and we're
seeing man we just don't treat our
elderly correctly that the fact that
they were able to die like that was
because we weren't on the watch in
general yeah Dana I'll go to you next i
I find it quite disgraceful that
Governor Cuomo while he's messing around
with swabs with his brother on CNN is
trying to pass the blame here for this
nursing home tragic disaster in New York
off to the president he knows darn well
other governors were given discretion to
in nursing homes and took a completely
different tact well and one of them was
the governor of Washington jay Inslee
another you know a fellow Democrat of
Andrew Cuomo now they had that terrible
outbreak in that one nursing home and we
all watched that as it started to unfold
and that's when he's really started to
understand that this virus was going to
be a killer I also noted that there was
a story in The New York Times this week
that if Cuomo had agreed to shut down
New York sooner like the same week that
Washington did he could have stopped 80%
of deaths in the state so you know we
start her Aldo asked me about President
Trump did he regret the lockdown I think
that this question should be posed to
Andrew Cuomo now he has said we didn't
have the information we did it no sir
but but jay Inslee had the same
information so I don't think that is
good enough and I think for the
accountability has to be there the other
thing I would say to Greg's point and
for Janice Dean you know I'm starting to
have I'm at the age now where I have
friends who are having to make
decisions about what they can do to care
for their parents and you know they've
got kids in college and they've got
their parents maybe having to go to a
retired living facility or assisted care
or even a nursing home and the stress of
thinking that your loved one is not
going to be getting be taken care of
it's a lot so I also agree with Greg on
that that you re thinking of how to
approach this and I don't think it's a
government solution but there has to be
more accountability and possibly even
dare I say it more regulation or at
least some checks on the system well
Katie I I find interesting too that
Governor Cuomo saying well we didn't
have all the information and that's why
we made these bad decisions but you
notice those same courtesies have not
been extended to President Trump at all
no and I think it's very important to
point out that the nursing homes in New
York were begging Andrew Cuomo not to
have this executive order they push back
as hard as they could in most cases to
say we do not have the ability to bring
people who are infected with kovat back
to into our facilities without putting
others in harm's way and Cuomo went
through with it and he can say he didn't
have all the information but at the same
time that you had the Javits Center that
was being built the the the Mercy ship
from the Navy that was sent up and had
the ability to take patients the
Secretary of Defense that will take
kovat patients if we need to those were
not used so at the same time that those
places sat empty Andrew Cuomo was still
enforcing this executive order to send
these patients back into nursing homes
and so you know they did what they could
to push back but the government the hand
of government was doing this I'm very
curious about whether people will vote
with their feet and leave places like
New York as a result of bad leadership
which not just results in bad
livelihoods but also in this case has
been very fatal for a number of families
her although your thoughts I got three
quick points number one my heart goes
out to genestein and her husband that's
just a horrible horrible loss Greg's
right nursing homes are disgustingly
oversized they're fat to take advantage
of government entitlement programs
beginning with Medicare and 1965
they've got a shrink in size they're
horrible they're their breeding grounds
for infection one person one elderly
person gets sick they all they all catch
whatever that one got and they and the
other point is you know we have to look
at Andrew Cuomo in the context of those
briefings that he's been doing every
single day and compare those to
President Trump
loved him but his his White House
briefings have been combative they've
been you know he's been punching down at
reporters you know you look at it you
say my god what's the president doing
slugging it out with the reporter who's
just trying to get face time compare
that with Cuomo's which was so orderly
you know well done graphically you know
the the the piper will come calling for
Andrew Cuomo eventually the press is
already on his case what about putting
infected people into these nursing homes
the the shine will dull over time but I
think in terms of communicating during
the crisis thank you think Governor
Cuomo did an excellent job tonight
coders were acting very differently in
the White House press corps than the
reporters who were questioning Andrew
Cuomo like they Andrew Coleman would say
paradoxical or Quinn and wouldn't get
pushed back and Trump would tout it and
the White House press corps would ask
questions about why he's calling you the
Chinese virus so I think that the
standard of how the reporters were
acting was a lot different as well just
to I just wanted to whatever aldo is is
pointing out is the attorney of the
eternal challenge with Trump and that is
are you willing to take an arrogant kind
of guy who gets the stuff done or would
you prefer something that's that appears
to be calm and sophisticated but ends up
killing or a creating disaster this is
always going to be the argument with
Trump is that it's a package deal you
get you don't know if Democrats could
choose if they could swap out Biden for
Andrew Cuomo I bet the majority of
Democrats would say yes we got about
Andrew Cuomo we got to go Cuomo was all
hat no cattle he was good at graphs he
wasn't much good at results